[Music]
every single day over 73 000 new babies
are born in India
[Music]
I've recently become a new mother and I
still remember the day I was in the
operation theater and the doctor showed
up my daughter the nurse then said
congratulations you have been blessed
with the baby girl
Nikita and aniket are new parents
and their baby girl Trisha is one of the
millions born across India this year
contributing to a historic milestone
India has now overtaken China as the
world's most populous country
what does this demographic shift mean
for India
can India cash in on its new role as the
world's most populous nation
for many Indians the fact that India has
taken the title as the world's most
populous nation was not exactly a
surprise it was a matter of when not if
India is a big country and we have had
so much of people that is also what
makes India India I mean we've always
lived you know with so many people
around so I don't think it's going to
change much for us
half of India's population is under the
age of 30 and around 12 million or so
people enter the market every year
looking for jobs
the challenge for India will be to
sustain economic expansion in the coming
decades or end up with an even higher
unemployment rate
you could look at it as a way of
creating more jobs you can push all the
infrastructure growth great highways are
being built at rapid Pace as we grew up
India was always a Services Country Now
Services plus manufacturing you call
India's China plus one but female
participation in the workforce remains a
problem for India's demographic
transformation
Indian women in recent years have
started joining the workforce but the
country still lags behind significantly
compared to other nations including
China
when there's quite Advanced but the
gender gap is huge so we have to invest
in technological uh exposure in
advancement for both girls and boys and
then we have to think about these young
people and their issues like age of
marriage we have to end child marriage
we need to educate them in higher
education finally we absolutely need to
ensure that India does not have a large
unemployed population whose aspirations
are not fulfilled because that is recipe
for disaster
closing the employment gap between men
and women could expand India's GDP by
close to a third by 2050 equating to
nearly 6 trillion dollars we will have
the opportunity where if we skill our
young people they can participate not
just in management fracturing but the
Inc development growth economic growth
of the country even though we have a
large population we have a shortage of
Professionals in India doctors in the
public health system this is a shortage
of teachers trained teachers so we have
to invest a lot in training
rapid progress on urbanization
infrastructure human development and
Manufacturing will be needed for decades
as the population continues to swell
despite concerns with sustaining India's
Rising population Nikita and aniket
remain optimistic
it's a good ERA for pressure I feel
because as a country we're growing and
we're on this you know rapid growth
phase and if we do really well I feel
the next decade could be really good for
us
please